okay muchachos it's your boy Sango
okay we're gonna play this game called
deluded mind or maybe it's men I don't
know
so we're gonna play this and we'll just
see what happens this scheme was $12 on
Steam and it just looks good basically
at this point it's just like if it looks
good it's gonna play good you know what
I'm saying baby you know I find that
essentially if it looks good there's
usually better gameplay not saying that
it can't be other way around that it was
terrible it can't be good gameplay but I
just found that most of the time if it
looks good I plays good walls most the
time it looks bad it's bad oh well we'll
just try it out you never know okay
let's do this new game deluded mind I
really don't know anything about this
nothing look good okay now I know more
stuff the game put these horrors it
scenes and jump scares well if you have
week horror pull up see the you know
like stay stay at the picnic area
okay stay at the watercooler you know
like we don't need water uh you know I
just play the game okay
I press kelp reminds me my Saturdays
after a Friday barn and you know waking
up where am I I like blockbuster again
and like I didn't even know blockbuster
still around you know
okay thank you thank you
sorry kind bulk that's F okay
[ __ ] you know not that you see it what
is that alright
J not buck mm okay look at this look at
this already a better game than most of
the ones I played holy cannoli
what is that spaghetti oh so is that
spaghetti isn't it is that left-mouse a
hello agent cat troll you probably can't
remember exactly why you're here and
that's why I'll briefly explain it to
you you and your stupid partner strum
did my apartment arrest me however you
didn't expect my ambush well it's too
late for you now maybe you should have
put on gas masks next time do you know
the strange feeling in your head that's
just a small dose of my miracle powder
we're winning we're partners he is
somewhere at the administration I'm
probably keeps wondering where he left
his fingers and her other eye the hell
up yes have you found out who martyred
your daughter Diana if tiny little tip
the killer wrote this letter best
regards
Kevin Ranger thanks for the Red Guards
it goes back to you okay let's do this
hello Xiao Xiao its depth its sang to do
it but it won't work so I gotta find
that key whoa when I run this [ __ ] okay
any goodies in here I'm looking for
goodies I'm gonna use oh okay I got it I
got an achievement already my first key
I can't let's do this uh pretty dark in
here maybe if there was a jump scare
well I gotta tell you I mean I missed it
it's too dark oh that happened
now I'm trying to drink this
I lost my gold member status at
Starbucks and you know it's been a rough
a rough couple nights ever since you
know like it's really sad I feel like I
put in my time and I I feel like I'm
better than green status okay I'll wait
what is this hey can I help you
is this coke forever I get tired that's
why so Isis ihq the face is telling
ma'am
oh [ __ ] I think I just [ __ ] lost two
orders
holy [ __ ] I turned so fast I literally
don't even know where the hell I am
but that [ __ ] is going on here I'm
trying to follow you [ __ ] Oh typical
Saturday from a-z you better man up you
know what they got I was like really
short out okay wait what I'm gonna crib
that's the hell of that hello sir Robert
best pencil home of the year
quality control I approp that Robert
Smith
oh [ __ ] who's gonna Kevin ring closer
five years 330 foot 330 days and that's
pretty I like pretty stuff anything in
here
I shall not lie okay hey you know
sunshine although my god was referring
this agony and over here at know it's
happened me why phone help it may place
got played like way by Bible a little
eyes why is he writing a letter how did
I got accept letters I thought he was
only like prayer form I guess everybody
works in mysterious ways
oh it's [ __ ] locked that much is
certain
sir [ __ ] dark think it's open is it
happen it is but I can't see [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] flashlight around here
flashlight plays flashlight I'm looking
for a flashlight eyes are on with these
people
no my guess I can't go there any
flashlights around here flashlights
people I'm looking
hello ma'am flashlight 9news a
flashlight
now how many jump scares are gonna be in
this game like 50/50 jump scares now
it's open I need a fire can flourish
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] scared me I'm scared
I'm scared oh [ __ ] man whoa where'd you
got sucked into something that's not
good I hear something you know just
don't get on the subway train that's the
worst thing you know like you gonna hang
over you on the subway train that's bad
they just never leads to a good time
okay that's counting on yeah I'm walking
but I don't know where
well I saw something look sir sir
oh okay I made it holy [ __ ] widow's dark
I would really like a flashlight and a
[ __ ] flashlights in here maybe just
check basin something options controls
camouflages F ok guess I don't have the
camera what is that baking soda doors
blocked in the storage room that's where
I can get my camera set the door no it's
so freakin dark in this game
administration Robert should be there
Robert Robert ain't me oh [ __ ]
okay and glowy [ __ ] custody [ __ ] this is
gonna be scary I don't know what the
[ __ ] is in there
very spooky though very spooky you know
this is all this [ __ ] is unlocked whoa
security is unlocked oh I can't do [ __ ]
I guess the guy doesn't I to use a
computer or maybe it's cuz he lost his
fingers too like we'll never really know
door block put that [ __ ] I don't know
the password insulated all I know is
that it is [ __ ] dark in here what
okay I got one
now [ __ ] that hurts close enough [ __ ]
that's pointless there's the one that is
that nothing I can't check in here hello
sir
how's your stay I am here to claim okay
Ted O's look what they're playing tennis
liquid a patient or infer from we can
all [ __ ] up just watch out for it it
says I guess that's that's all one five
does each one have like a hidden thing
in there
because that one was really hard to find
one-five the [ __ ]
on
that is a number right
hmm no way Schaffer Journal
zero zero one five okay try that get out
my way
that's fun
and huh
it's 2008 there's huh
let the [ __ ] nice more letters right the
door always blocked [ __ ]
let's see here any more numbers I have
to be going very far that holy [ __ ] ham
and salmon storage room there's more
numbers throughout here I'm really sure
hmm ain't [ __ ] locked kind of in that
room it'll be more gotta be
anything on that way no okay what I say
it I say it Hilaire as day first one Oh
like my love babies hmm look what sells
that guy into the end five [ __ ]
you see any letters it's any [ __ ]
glowing letters cuz I don't see [ __ ] I
don't see [ __ ] in here hey well wish I
could say some [ __ ] there's a pile of
[ __ ] or something look at you know I
don't say any of that what is that
lights that light works how do I get
more lights working on I'm looking I'm
looking
I don't say [ __ ] I knew our letters huh
any of my letters I wish there were more
letters the [ __ ] am I missing something
now I'm missing something this early
series here I want five
Ted this
okay maybe I'll go back to like the
beginning but what is that carl
powershell service
it's so [ __ ] dark so [ __ ] dark
place up in the Security office gonna
weird anything I was sticking out what
is that
Oh is a TV massive okay
freaking dark in here darkus [ __ ] and
darkening yeah custody get it
anything in there
nothing in here they're all looked
thoroughly looked anything over here Oh
what
Oh ting heaping what is that what is
that okay here we go yeah we go here's
the password so it's five oh [ __ ]
the first thing to look at is the pipes
the pipes here they're the [ __ ] theory
I'm looking I don't see anything too
cool about them maybe there's just
something near the pipes
what is that [ __ ] speaker
there's three pipes I guess we go to the
storage boxes that's it maybe it's like
three something one two three four five
six seven eight one two three four five
six seven one here it's five
what the [ __ ]
anyway what now when you find out how
many are in here real quick
and there's the boxes
so it's like maybe these boxes [ __ ] that
is but let me count how many are in here
one two three four five right now one
two three four it's eight total yeah
okay so that is
maybe not that right pipes and is like
multiple pipes four pipes right here
looks like it just looks like the pipes
let see [ __ ] here
I hate more pipes okay what is that
oh five okay here we go okay so it's
five blank one five
this is the bathroom yeah - there we go
we got it guys we're so smart [ __ ]
and get - one day
okay here we go here we go 5 to 1 5 5 to
1 5 what
five to
it's a decoy house is that
definitely five that's a [ __ ] five you
find a box a box of [ __ ] I don't see a
box of [ __ ] on here
a box of shite [ __ ]
you just check that is indeed a - I
can't really see anything else you guys
had one beer with a seven five to seven
five
I'm sure that there we go is a seven
I don't know cliff no [ __ ] seven no
think I one [ __ ] week a seven saving
up
so I'm just [ __ ] knock from me I
heard you [ __ ] you knocked for me did
you
an actor eryk know why maybe you're
afraid okay
develop the tiptoes no patience no
longer needs out foods even for $2,000
of Mahad okay this is December 23rd 2008
so the other one is Oh later okay
[ __ ] dark
jump-scare
again dark as galini's
I guess you had to go in here right dark
[ __ ] that how you're not going down
there yet examination room
jump-scare holy [ __ ] that's scary
what is that try to get it on that thing
[ __ ] it's just saw it [ __ ] okay I
got it
I'm going in now got in
huh
okay anything in here any pistachios or
something I can't help in this all right
to get to the next area
okay yes I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] just
going for it
I'm just crawl in there okay
later three people three monster every
five minutes backwards in his cell
okay just can you [ __ ] up one
we're walking backwards in his cell and
a [ __ ] nut job
I don't know what that's about I don't
know I don't know if you think I know
you are mistaken
how the [ __ ] oh my god
I can wind it anyway I got a keycard
so can I go back to that I place like
you think it's over here now they got a
keycard I wonder if I can go in yeah way
go hello hello
is this a lot it's all blocked
mmm-hmm curious mean Billy
walking backwards [ __ ] happening
next episode for watching
[Music]